nuevo día de luto en río de janeiro
donde esta mañana la policía ha llevado
a cabo una macro operación contra el
narcotráfico en la favela de vila
cruzeiro el área norte de la ciudad de
momento el saldo es de 22 muertos siete
heridos y ya es la segunda operación más
mortífera de la ciudad recordamos que en
mayo del año pasado en una favela vecina
en jacarezinho hubo otra operación con
28 muertos y fue tan violenta que la
misma o no las naciones unidas pidieron
una investigación independiente la razón
de esta operación esta vez ha sido una
persecución contra los principales
narcotraficantes de la ciudad del
comando rojo la principal facción que
opera en el narcotráfico de río de
janeiro según la policía había varias
personas huidas de favelas que habían
sido reprimidas y por esta razón vila
cruzeiro se había convertido en el
epicentro del crimen y el responsable
del 80 por ciento de los tiroteos en la
ciudad sin embargo el ministerio público
federal ha hecho ha abierto una
investigación porque cree que no eran a
tanta violencia el objetivo original era
arrestar a algunos sospechosos pero si
abrió fuego durante la madrugada y la
policía según su propio relato se vio
obligada a responder hay entre las
víctimas una mujer de 43 años que estaba
caminando en una calle aledaña y fue
alcanzada por una bala perdida y lo que
más llama la atención en esos casos que
los cariocas están divididos en las
redes sociales algunos apoyan esta
operación cansados dicen de la violencia
y otros reclaman contra otro episodio de
violencia policial